over the last three months the cost of
treating unvaccinated american covid19
patients amounted to at least 5.7
billion dollars according to research by
the kaiser family foundation that number
was at least 3.7 billion dollars in
august connected to the roughly 187
thousand coveted 19 hospitalizations
that month that could have been
prevented by vaccination according to
kaiser the average covet 19 hospital
bill is approximately 20 000
however they note that number is likely
a conservative estimate due to
significant variations in the cost of
treatment across the country
due to laws preventing insurers from
charging unvaccinated people higher
premiums the kaiser report said the bill
will fall on everyone as the sick will
pay only a small share of the cost
directly this places a higher burden on
taxpayers and risks higher insurance
premiums for businesses and workers
according to the report and the
unvaccinated will face higher
out-of-pocket costs for hospitalization
by august 2021 72 of the largest health
plans stopped cost-sharing for covet-19
treatment according to kaiser the vast
majority of hospitalizations and nearly
all deaths from covet 19 are an
unvaccinated people the surge in demand
for what few medicines are licensed to
treat covet 19 in the u.s has triggered
nationwide shortages and rationing of
scarce supplies
you